we want to start with a developing story
in nigeria where reports are coming in
of another mass school abduction this
time in the northwestern kaduna state
authorities say gunman seized a group of
students in a raid on a forestry college
on the outskirts
of the state capitol kaduna witnesses
said around
30 female students were abducted it is
the fourth mass kidnapping from a school
in nigeria since
december and let's get the very latest
on the story now we can go to abuja and
speak to our correspondent standing by
for us there idris
idris it's good to see you what is the
latest that you can tell us
well the latest we have is that head
count is still going
on to know the exact number of female
students taken from that school
the abductor stomp the school at night
as usual
just the way they did it before and now
pick
the female student what is surprising is
why
only female student this time around
because it's a
co-education school where there are male
and they are females but their
interest happens to be on the female
student whom they have taken away to the
bush
military and security personnel they
have been chasing them
to see how they can rescue this female
student
idris you mentioned that this is the
fourth kidnapping of school students
there since december and authorities
have promised that students
are safe so why do these kidnappings
keep happening
well is an indication of the growing
insecurity in nigeria
that is number one the kidnapping is
another indication of
bad governance and they're related to
poverty because
those who are doing this the hate men
complain that they've been neglected for
long
but it is a reality of failure of so
many things
because this is not the first time a
school has been
attacked right from 2014 when it happens
in chibok
we're still having it even more was more
frequent
so the concern is that what is the
government doing the government just
yesterday had a press conference by the
national security advisor
saying that they are doing something
warning those who are doing it
even coming out to say that there are
some who are cashing on what is
happening
on the kidnappings in nigeria an
interest i can imagine that
parents are angry and frustrated i mean
what are some of the reactions that
you're seeing there
it's a reaction of frustration an
action of anger from nigerians saying
why again why again why is it happening
again and again and again without
practical solution to it
that there are two divisions some are
even saying okay let us go for amnesty
and some are saying no there shouldn't
be amnesty for these bandits
so nigerians are frustrated because
after a long time of closure of school
schools were just open after covet and
now
most schools in the northwest have been
closed children are at home
and then coupled with the economic
situation is
a kind of multiple problems facing
nigerians now
our correspondent idris reporting from
abuja
thank you very much for that update
you